my name's AD venture Minh adventurer  Minh time of the hunt for adventure  again through the new fractured world of  warlock tune a fantasy war game first up  is the jungle world where the monsters  are totally awesome  actually it appears to be a tortoise and  since it's turn-based the only pause  you'll be pressing here the paws of  these murderous bears next up is the  undead world which poses a serious  question how do you kill that which does  not live with strategy and swords my  trusty dragon and I head to the moon  world not because it is easy but because  it is hard and dangerous and filled with  giant killer robots only a lunatic who  would live on the moon now we're off to  the lava world  it looks friendly and warm and good god  what is that  from kids this fantas a war gaming is no  joke warlock two more warfare more  monsters pure ecstasy